joyas you know the opening sequence is
awesome yeah I'd love art I'm not in it
so I can yeah I loved I just love to
know a little bit about how it was
conceived and executed
[Music]
about
when I first read the script you know I
was like this this is a potential here
to do something really cool but I was
like how can I get the audience to feel
really immersed and I wanted to really
be subjective for them when you do a
longer take that that feeling that
first-person feeling it helped and so
that's where it came from was just like
how do I get the audience there it was
very physically demanding and I mean
this is my first time you know dabbling
into the action stuff just trying to add
on the fact that you're acting that
you're running out of breath can kind of
freak you out but they were a really
patient
we had a great diving team and they had
me you know spend a lot of time with the
divers and get certified you know and
all that stuff so acting that out was a
lot of fun and I was really proud of the
final product so it was all worth it
we built this true to life secret Erin
and we stuck it on this giant gimbal
machine which tilts left right up and
down a 45 degree angle so we literally
had out Lee Javan playing boys dangling
450 alive when you see people flying
across the wall and their bodies blowing
up and bullets are flying all those are
squibs all that's real all the guys find
option is real they blew up the side of
the plane when the plane dips and goes
down they had I don't know how many you
know pounds of fuel pumping into that
back but it was like when that high it
came out it was so hot in there from it
was already not very getting with up
there because you're stuck in this thing
with 40 guys or whatever I don't there's
a lot of guys and a camera crew it is so
close to phobic and then when you get
outside it's like oh it's such a big one
and then you go back in and I think
that's one of the things you've really
mastered in this film that you created a
world that is soap and evil but Julius
had a vision and he stuck to it and yeah
he always knew what that was going to be
and it really came out yeah the way they
stick together is really about
everyone was those crazy but JJ said
just go for it you know and it was like
a really expensive very expensive
experiment that paid off I feel like
it's a ferocious war movie but it's also
like a sick monster movie too which is
amazing what part of that did you have
the most fun leaning into I'd done
action before in my previous movie and
I'd never ventured into the horror
sci-fi before and so definitely the the
horror site vileness and I got to do all
this old school analog really cool
in-camera prosthetics and we've got like
people of course who has this amazing
Pacific City war every day and was in a
chair for five hours thank you don't
mention it don't mention the war and we
also did this really cool thing where a
guys snaps his neck back and we did that
with puppetry and and and and old-school
animatronics and I think the audience
gets off that because it's visceral and
it you can feel the texture and nothing
beats reality you know I think that the
transitional element from going from
real to genre was really fun to watch
how that was how the movie tried to
transcend the movie that you were
watching that you thought you were
watching and I think that they did that
really smoothly and thought it happened
really well and it wasn't there wasn't a
Joel to kind of ease you into the fact
that this was an alternate University
we're gonna feel some things and see
some things that you didn't think you
were gonna see but yeah I thought that I
thought the way they melded that with
the genre element you know that is an
overarching thing to say but that was
kind of my favorite thing about a
seamless transition
you